how's it going man might have been back
and we just learned a new ability what
it's answer me confidence bells you can
do it cracker sounds like drugs to me
what do I do
hey I feel a lot more confident yeah
anymore
whoa this sounds like when I was a
little kid and I jumped red in the water
without those and I nearly [ __ ]
drowned all right
so now we can swim underwater and [ __ ]
but how the [ __ ] did we do it
oh I just hold B I here we go yeah wait
yeah what we're gonna conquer space are
you all right that car cat dog you can
mail that [ __ ] oh I'm out of the poop
oh sweet
now where do we go oh I guess I don't
even know anymore digging the music
[Music]
thank uh better put the [ __ ] so what
am I supposed to do with this seriously
okay I'm just gonna roll it up to mouth
then I mean what else do you do what
would you do if you had a bottle of poop
I mean not a bottle of probative all
over it because bigger does it really is
it becoming bigger or am I drunk I think
I'm drunk no way is it all right let's
do this
no no what are you doing okay this place
is shite sir
really you're [ __ ] crazy man I wait
here I don't ship the [ __ ] out of this
basket [ __ ] it I have a wallet for I
don't need you talk to women I have a
bollock oh I could just [ __ ] that oh
we're gonna kill him we're gonna kill
him don't [ __ ] this up heads don't [ __ ]
your ball up on just he could have just
[ __ ] throw a TMT in his mouth
why did it have to throw a ball of
Tomatina
I'll never understand this [ __ ] game
another bullet burn the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do with another fall apart
[Music]
continues so I gotta go all the way up
again well [ __ ]
leather away I don't know about you bros
but my shits doesn't look like that
I gotta die now oh no boy laughs oh I
met it thank you buck
I want to I can how big I can make this
wallop oh I hope I would be awesome if
you could make it just the size of this
[ __ ] mountain in this [ __ ] room
Katamari dreams poo edition love it love
it
I'm not sure why they haven't invented
this before now come on name you just
Yellin of my bollock oh man oh [ __ ] off
what am I supposed to do here well what
the [ __ ] what the hell did I just do oh
shut up
give me another ball I don't need
another was that good for if I roll you
in here what's going on here now tell me
okay over the shape Mouse's thumbs over
here galactic gun the fastest is napping
in I'm out of here
you'll enjoy yeah Ike just some money up
day if you can be asked to get it see is
there's some see see as my friend sorry
about Tesla man it maybe he just went
shopping you never know about these
things
alright this is that don't say anyone
mmm-hmm okay really want all right so
this Wow hey be nice to sweet corn all
we gotta do is send [ __ ] corn back to
this [ __ ] come in sweet corn that
was enlightening
ah who gives a [ __ ] sweet cold I'm sorry
I love you but I love
it's always romantic to burp when you
talk about love I know that one
oh no it's a just that's the shower
command
oh man oh man a little fun fact I get my
you know I'm scared from playing horror
games I get that from my from my dad
because he's [ __ ] scared as hell of
like anything the only scary movie my
dad ever watched was jaws and he keeps
telling me about how how scary he
thought it was but I don't even know you
awesome skills man alright I could just
jump over I'm an idiot oh well [ __ ]
happens
ah I get it come here sweet corn come
here [ __ ] oh damn that [ __ ] you
shall be sacrificed
sweet cons but I want to laugh I don't
give a [ __ ] literally I can use this how
much it I could go all day with that
joke okay the only thing that I eat that
really makes me fart is raisins
it makes me fart like a [ __ ] but
I love raisins they're so delicious it's
not fair [ __ ] if I get one more I'm
gonna die alright there's another one
here [ __ ] random [ __ ] falling why
alright here's a lot of help what is
that guy doing that hey MA Hey
how do I get to you I can see that so
many oh we hate what's that uh-huh well
I guess we got to keep sacrificing this
sweet corn at least I have full help
snap come back yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you
ah [ __ ] oh sure how's class class Otto's
as PewDiePie prefer after
the Tatas okay oh and this should be the
last one I think if they are all [ __ ]
happy here's all this time sweetheart
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] it's
beautiful
oh no not sweet cards I love that me me
me me my am the great mighty Oh I am
going to throw my [ __ ] from my chocolate
starfish how about some scat you little
[ __ ] what how did he call me our buttons
catchy little [ __ ]
oh it dings now what how can you escape
my toilet paper how about some scratch
little [ __ ] best song ever
[Music]
they don't make games like this anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I can use that one anymore
[ __ ] we gotta go to another one
oh this three of them the classic boss
battle number we don't have any shockers
oh [ __ ]
this song is so [ __ ] awesome
sing come on yes did I get him I think I
got it well I gotta hit him again stop
throwing [ __ ] at me no hell did that hit
me sing
[Music]
stop Navigon great magical now happy now
I'm really getting draw the battle like
a deadly ticklish it see little tags not
little time knock you out with all my
Babar gonna take your head off my
[ __ ] game Alan oh [ __ ] is today girl
[Music]
I'm gonna guess who's coming yet yes
that's me on that bench
come at me bro
yes come on come on
it's gonna that exploded don't fail me
now bro we came so far don't sing linkin
park what the [ __ ] man
[Music]
I thought bees kill em hi guys the great
mighty poo is just too powerful powerful
[Music]
Concord has taken a lot of [ __ ] shut up
drank some beer tonight
[Music]
that is all about movement
I hope we're done with the fart jokes
I'm getting a really [ __ ] signal
whoever did that sound effects for those
that was supposed a big boss battle ever
all right brothers hope you enjoyed this
episode like a pirate if a dead
subscribe to become a bro today and I
will see you in next episode over I'm a
nobody bros say awesome
[Music]